a pulmonary embolism is a blood clot in
the veins of the lung it is one of the
most dangerous types of venous
thromboembolism which is the general
term for when blood clots form in veins
pulmonary embolism occurs when a small
blood clots or embolus breaks off from a
larger clot or from bus and travels to
the lung where it can cause a
potentially life-threatening blockage
symptoms include chest pain shortness of
breath heart palpitations coughing up
blood fainting and in severe cases signs
of shock and low blood pressure these
symptoms are caused by damage to the
lungs which also affects the heart the
right ventricle in particular the right
side of the heart pumps blood to the
lungs and is finner
and weaker than the left when a
pulmonary embolism blocks the blood
vessels of the lung there's a sudden
increase in pressure in the pulmonary
artery this increases the afterload of
the right ventricle which is the
pressure the heart must work against to
pump blood as a result in some patients
the right ventricle has to work harder
to keep pumping blood but after a
certain threshold it fails this disrupts
blood flow to vital organs leading to
death a process known as hemodynamic
collapse individuals at increased risk
of pulmonary embolism include all the
people those with pneumonia those
undergoing surgery and long hospital
stays people who have major bone
fractures with trauma and people who are
immobilized for long periods other
medical conditions can also be a risk
factor such as genetic diseases of the
coagulation cascade sickle-cell disease
and chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease there are a number of treatments
available for pulmonary embolism
including anti from Bostic treatment
with drugs such as direct all
anticoagulants vitamin K antagonists and
low molecular weight heparin there are
also medical procedures such as
reperfusion therapy to restore blood
flow to the blocked vessels despite
these treatments at
one in ten patients will die of venous
thromboembolism within one year and at
least one in five patients will have
recurrence within five years if there's
venous thromboembolism developed without
a clear cause so-called idiopathic from
where embolism patients who survived can
develop post pulmonary embolism syndrome
a poorly understood condition
characterized by exercise intolerance
shortness of breath and a reduction in
quality of life as research continues a
better understanding of pulmonary
embolism and improved treatment should
lead to better chances of survival and a
better quality of life for those with
this condition
you